your fave celebrity couples cannot keep
their hands off each other
Ryan Seacrest is close to locking in his
five hundred and thirty fifth job Plus
beyoncé and jay-z's finally welcomed
their twins
ah so when I love you Baba
what's up world this day has been a long
time coming
babies have arrived and so has this show
welcome to the daily Deni I'm Danny
direct oh I love alliteration but I'm
also an easy online host and producer
pop culture junkie and devout Beyonce
Stan everyday I'm serving you a daily
dose of the biggest stories in Hollywood
Plus red carpet interviews exclusive
gossip and Beyonce whenever I can
stinker in boiler alerts that will be
every day except today I didn't even
have to try so like my birthday Blue Ivy
is officially a big sister to two more
sibs for grandpa Matthew Knowles
confirmed the big news Sunday morning
tweeting a balloon covered birthday card
and the caption they're here by the way
how sweet of Matthew to plug he's on
Instagram handle in that card now we
have not heard from Beyonce herself yet
but the speculation is she gave birth to
a girl and a boy there have been two
separate deliveries of blue and pink
balloons to UCLA Medical Center where we
also spotted jay-z's SUV everyday last
week and again this morning and as if
caring for two newborns wasn't enough
mister Carter also announced he is
dropping his thirteenth studio album 444
on Friday he gave fans a sneak peak with
this teaser clip featuring Danny Glover
and rehersal Ali's letter to my dad that
I never grow speeches I prepared a ton
of Lascaux way to try to distract us
there mister Carter you know et has also
learned that B has a special production
plan to introduce the babies to the
world now are we surprised by that
because who can forget the pregnancy
announcement heard all around the world
Twitter said there were half a million
tweets about B after this photo in the
first 45 minutes alone so you know
however she introduces those twins it's
be epic alright by the way I did of
course get a gift for the twins hang on
for a sec they're pretty good starting
with I got you guys a Barbies of your
mother
enter her in her heyday Destiny's Child
and by the way a Tina Knowles creation
so there you go and of course every
birth is not complete without some
flowers except however these are
legitimately and I'm being honest here
are from Beyonce's Grammys performance
where she was carrying them in that
belly of hers so you guys here you go
memories this is where it all started
this when we learned about Jeff I
already love you
welcome to the world all right guys we
do have to move on from B and J cause
there's a lot of other stories to talk
about including some celeb couples who
were busy loving up on each other over
the weekend J Lo and a rod lit up Paris
France not only showing off some fierce
fashion but also some PDA they were
holding hands stopping for ice cream
J Lo's all nuzzled into her man these
two are so cute
and they've only been together for four
months a source tells ET j-rod are going
strong and having so much fun together
now if I were to rate these two on a
scale from one to John Legend and
Chrissy Teigen who are the ultimate
couple gold I give them a solid 7.5 the
relationship is still kind of fresh
they're cute but kept they're a little
too low-key for my taste but they did
get an extra 1 and a half for ice cream
because ice cream giving them a run for
their money though is Blake and Gwen our
favorite cowboy ring in his 41st
birthday on Sunday and Glenn was not shy
about sharing some snaps with her man
and this armadillo cake she captioned
this cute video of Blake celebrating the
birth of my besties hash tag favorite
and in this pic of the two smooches Gwen
wrote I get to kiss on the birthday boy
hashtag happy birthday cowboy I mean
come on that is a 9 on the John and
Chrissy scale I'm also gonna give them a
10 for selfie skills way to go there
Gwen are you guys are you having fun I'm
having a blast all right one more story
before we leave I've got an update on
the American Idol business for you now
if you've been following the show is
coming back to a DC with Katy Perry as a
judge but what's the deal with Ryan
Seacrest source close to the American
Idol production does confirmed
t-that Ryan is in discussion to become
hosts and reports put his price tag at
between ten and fifteen million dollars
I get this producers want him so badly
it reportedly bumped up the offer with
an executive producer credit now I know
what you think in between his new live
gig with Kelly Ripa his radio show and
not to mention producing the Kardashian
franchises he doesn't need it but let me
ask you this what is American Idol
without Ryan Seacrest it's nothing the
show has yet to pick the other two
judges but rumors are swirling that
Lionel Richie could be joining Katy on
the panel and when et caught up with his
daughter Nicole Richie recently she
seems to think he's a good fit to
Nicholas my dad would consider it he
loved TV he loves the camera and he
loves having all the attention so I'm
sure he would do it
I feel like MVP Jake please bishop he's
probably like knocking on the door like
I'm still here oh he's still around all
right in fact Lionel is ramping up his
all the hits tour with Mariah Carey
which kicks off July 21st and Idol
begins their auditions in August so time
will tell if they landed Lionel all
right guys that is it for us today thank
you thank you thank you so much for
watching be sure to like and share this
video let me know what you think in the
comments section below I want to hear
from you because I'm here for it all of
course hit subscribe to e t--'s youtube
channel for more daily dennee and also
another amazing youtube franchise
interviews under the influence we've got
a new one today where we're day drinking
with Little Big Town to check that out
and of course stick with each online for
all of these stories and a whole lot
more thanks again for watching guys I'm
going to running man out of here been a
lot of fun Thank You congratulations
being Jay woo